what has changed with russia and ukraine  that you are i'm sure you're following  the story very closely what's changed in  the last three weeks you know i'm afraid  it may move us closer and closer to the  edge you know of that nuclear precipice  uh  putin has getting  even though russia is an authoritarian  state  you know he has  lots of different advisors from the  military from the intelligence services  of the services the military services  compete with each other  and uh  and and they're probably making  recommendations for all  a wide variety of options nuclear and  non-nuclear options  uh for putin to execute  and uh uh  the longer the conventional war appears  to go against russia  uh the more likely it becomes that one  of these options will be executed